I want to take up in volume 12 and march the 8th 1921.
With her love, the Virgin called the word to incarnate himself in her womb,
and with her love and by fusing herself in the divine will,
Louisa calls the divine will to have life on the earth within herself.
So while praying, Louisa said, "I was fusing all of myself in the divine will."
There's something to really take note of. Make sure you do fuse all of yourself in all of him.
And my sweet Jesus came out from my interior and throwing his arm around my neck,
which is Song of Songs chapter 2 verse 6. He said, "And for what I'm going to read
now I want to give you Isaiah 64 verses 1 to 5. My daughter," he said, "with her love
and with her prayers, with her annihilation, my mother called me from heaven to earth to incarnate
myself in her womb." Now notice with her annihilation. You meet this word very frequently in these
writings, and her annihilation means her absolute selflessness, her absolute nothingness,
because annihilation means wiped out. So it's absolute nothingness, which I think is a very
wonderful thing, because that's the Lord asking us to go into our absolute nothingness.
And you see, nothingness is much, much lower than humility. If you can say you're humble,
there's still a bit of you there. So with her absolute nothingness,
she called me from heaven to earth to incarnate myself in her womb.
So then he says, "Louisa, you with your love and with your continuous dissolving yourself in my
volition, will call my will to have life on the earth within you." You see, that's what we're all
trying to do now, is that the more frequently we fuse ourselves in the divine will, the more the
divine will can come to have life on the earth in and through us, and we become his throne on earth,
and it's from that throne that he will rule the earth. And he said, "Once you've done this,
then you will give me life in other creatures, because as you know, when you fuse, you are in
contact not only with all that is in the divine will, that means all creatures as well." So this
would fulfill Joel chapter 3 verses 1 to 5 that the Spirit of God will in the end descend upon
all flesh. However, Jesus said, "Know that my mother called me from heaven to earth inside her womb,
since the act she did was a unique act, which will never be repeated again." In other words,
Jesus will never again be incarnated in anybody's womb. I enriched her with all graces, in other
words, for this unique act. Whatever we have to do, the Lord gives us the grace. He empowers us to do
it. So since Blessed Mother had to do something that no other human being would ever be asked to do,
then he has to give her a unique grace for that. I endowed her with so much love as to make her
surpass the love of all creatures united together. If anybody wants to know how great she is, that's it.
Well, that's one of the ways of saying it. To make her love, surpass the love of all creatures
united together. I gave her primacy in the privileges, in the glory, in everything.
I could say that the whole of the eternal one reduced himself to one single point and poured
himself into her in torrents, in immense seas, so much so that all remain below her.
Now, I want you to notice something. We've been told in all the messages leading up to here
that the divine will is a singularity, a single point, and everything is in that single point.
And yet the divine majesty is an immensity beyond which any of us could imagine.
So how you square the immensity with the singularity is mathematics beyond me.
But it's simply a reality. So what Jesus is saying here is that the immensity of the divine person
actually reduced himself to that singularity to be able to enter our mother's womb and become
incarnate within her. That makes a enormous sense. Look at the humility of God.
If only we would look at the humility of God, it would wipe out our puny pride and our puny self
glory in which we bloat ourselves in the most ridiculous way. He who has everything,
he who is everything, he who needs nothing, he who's infinitely happy, infinitely great,
infinitely love, infinitely everything would reduce himself to this nothing
in order to become incarnate in our mother's womb. No wonder pride is the worst of all sins
because to have our not only nothingness but our filthy nothingness to stand up against that
is beyond frightening. It's beyond frightening.
I could say, Jesus said, that the whole of the eternal one, the infinite immensity of God
reduced himself to one single point and poured himself upon her in torrents,
in immense seas. So I want to give you there Sam 36 verses 9 to 10, the torrents of his delight,
so much so that all remain below her. Not only do all of us individually remain below her but all
of us collectively remain below her, including the angels. As you call my will into yourself,
he said, this too is a unique act, therefore for the decorum of my will, which must dwell in you,
I must pour into you so much grace, so much love as to make you surpass all other creatures.
Now what is unique in Louisa is that she is to put the key into history and open up the era of the
new and divine holiness. So the specific way that she is to call the divine will into herself
so that he can descend upon the earth, that too is unique. So that she will surpass all creatures
as well, but of course below mother. And since my will has supremacy overall, my will is eternal,
my will is immense, my will is infinite, I must communicate this to the one in whom the life of my
will must have its beginning and its completion, endowing and reaching her with the same qualities
of my will, giving her supremacy overall, it's everything to do with him. If he is to come
and make his dwelling in us, if he's to set up his throne in us, he has to have a palace that's
worthy of him and he alone can make that palace worthy of him. And so he has to endow, he has to
enrich, he has to do everything. Nobody can do anything that's worthy of him, he has to do everything
himself. And therefore, giving Louisa supremacy overall, my eternal volition will take the past,
the present and the future. It will reduce them to one single point and will pour them
into you. Now again, in notice, the eternal will, which of course is the essence of God himself,
is now reducing past, present and future everything to one single point. That's why when we enter into
the divine will, we meet past, present and future. And we pray and intercede for past, present and
future, because that's what's there. That's what we meet. And we'll pour them into you. My will is
eternal and wants to have there, sorry, my will is eternal and wants to have life there where it
finds eternity. It is immense and it wants life in the immensity. It is infinite and wants to find
infinity. How can I find this if I don't pour them into you ahead of time? So this is the
prevenient grace that must be given if we're to be able to respond. You can understand now
why Louisa has been reacting for quite some time. Who am I? I mean, I'm absolutely nothing. I can't do
this. You seem to be choosing the wrong person. None of us can be worthy of this or even worthy
to talk about it, let alone experience it. And so the Lord himself has to prepare Louisa.
Now we're at the end of Volume 12 and he has spent all of this time preparing her for this.
Therefore you and I can't skip the stages that lead to this. That would be a frightful affront to the
Lord. On hearing this, Louisa said she was frightened and terrified. If I wrote this, it's because
obedience imposed itself. And I said, Jesus, what are you saying? You really want to confuse me and
humiliate me to the dust. I feel that I can't even tolerate what you're saying. I feel a terror that
frightens me. And Jesus' response to this was what I say to you will serve for myself. In other words,
he has to prepare a place worthy of himself. Otherwise he can't come. The Lord will not
come to live in Suridge. Hebrews 12, 14. Without holiness, no one can even see God. Matthew 5, 8,
only the pure in heart will see God. And so Jesus says to her that if he is to come down to the earth,
then it's absolutely necessary that he does this. It's necessary for the sanctity and the
dignity of my will. I do not lower myself to reside where I do not find the things that belong to me.
You will be nothing but the depository. So I want to give you Isaiah 57 verse 15.
I want to give you Revelation 21, 27. And I want to give you Habakkuk 1, 13. I love that text in
Habakkuk. Lord, your eyes are too holy to even look upon evil. So he will not come to Suridge.
And so Louisa will be the depository of such a great good. And he says to her,
you must keep these gifts jealously. Therefore pluck up courage and do not fear. So Louisa is
terrified of this new office that's given to her. If she thought that all that he gave to her in the
past in her office of victim soul was great and terrible. It's nothing at all to what he's offering
now. So March the 12th in 1921. The divine will. The grain must become food and Louisa is the straw.
So if you want to go for the grain that must fall into the ground and die in order to produce
fruit, that's John 12, 24. Louisa said, I was saying to myself, my queen mother provided the blood
in order to form the humanity of Jesus within her womb. And I, what will I give in order to form
the life of the divine will within me? So Jesus said, my daughter, you will provide me the straw
in order to form the ear in which I will be the grain. I will give my will as food to nourish
all the souls who will want to eat of the divine will. You will be the straw which will preserve the
grain. And here in this Louisa said, my love, my office of serving you is straw is ugly because
the straw is thrown away. It's burned and it has no value. And Jesus said, yeah, the straw is necessary
to the ear of grain. If it wasn't for the straw, the grain could not mature or multiply. The poor
straw serves as a garment in the defense of the grain. If the burning sun invests it, the straw
defends it from the excess of heat so as not a lettuce wither. If frost or rain or something else
invades the grain, the straw takes all of these evils upon itself. Therefore, one can say that
the straw is the life of the grain. And if the straw is thrown away and burnt, this is when it is
separated from the grain. The grain of my will is not subject to growing or decreasing. And as much
as they take of it, it will not diminish one single grain. Because we've heard that endlessly
now about the sun, it won't increase or decrease. The stars won't increase or decrease. No matter
how much we take from God, it doesn't decrease him remotely. So the grain is my will and it's not
subject to growing or decreasing. As much as they take from it, it will not diminish one single bit.
So your straw will be necessary to me. It will serve me as a garment, as defense,
defending the rights of my volition. Therefore, there's no danger that you may be separated from me.
After a little while he came back, and Louisa said to him, my life, Jesus, if the souls who will
live in your volition will be rainbows, can you tell me what will be the colors? Now you can
understand that the priests are asking Louisa these questions and therefore she has to ask Jesus.
And all goodness Jesus said, their qualities and colors will be fully divine. This is God's rainbow
in God's sky, indicating God's rain upon the earth. And so he tells us how you would recognize
somebody living in the divine will. So here's another very, very important piece of discernment
for us. They will blaze with the most beautiful and bright colors. And these colors are love,
goodness, wisdom, power, sanctity, mercy, and justice. I want to give you Galatians 5-22 for
the fruits of the Spirit, love, joy, peace, patience, kindness, goodness, and so on.
The variety of these colors will be as light in the darkness of the night. And by virtue of these
colors they will make the day rise in the mind of creatures. Now the darkness of the night are the
people living in the sewage. They're living a horrendous life. And looking at a person like this
will show them that they can rise from the dead and that they can live a new life as well.
So March the 17th, 1921. Jesus makes Louisa pass from the office of his humanity on the earth
to the office which he's will operated in his humanity. So here's Louisa and her mission
changing completely. She has a new office. Louisa was saying to Jesus, "I don't know. At the more
you say you give to me by means of your holy volition, the more wretched and ugly I feel,
I should feel better. I should feel more good. Instead, it's all the opposite."
I want to give you Isaiah chapter 6 verses 1-6. Isaiah was a good man. He was a holy man. He
was a prophet. God was using him to speak to the people. But when he actually encountered the glory
of God in the temple, his reaction was, "What a wretched man I am. I'm a man of unclean lips."
And I belong to a people of unclean lips. It's only when we actually touch the glory of God that we
realize not only our nothingness but our sinful nothingness. And Louisa is touching the glory of
God at a very deep level. And the more she does, the more wretched she feels. Now if in our spiritual
life you feel great and good and glorious and wonderful and everything worry. Because touching
the greatness and the holiness of God makes us touch our sinfulness and our nothingness.
Jesus told me, "My daughter, the more the grain of my will grows in you, the more you will feel
the misery of your straw." In fact, when the ear begins to form, grain and straw are one single thing,
John 14-21. But when the life of the ear keeps forming as the grain matures, the straw is detached
from it and remains only as the defense of the grain. Therefore, the more wretched you feel,
the more the grain of my will actually keeps forming in you and is close to perfect maturation.
The straw within you is nothing other than your weak nature which living together with the sanctity
and the nobility of my will feels its misery even more. There you have it.
2 Corinthians 12-9, "My power works best in weakness."
So here is the point of change. Louisa has completed her mission of victim soul and is given the
unique mission of opening the era of the divine will. So Jesus added, "My beloved,
up to now you have done before me the office which my humanity had upon the earth that's been
victim soul and intercessor. Now I want to change your office, giving you another one more noble
and more extensive. I want to give you the office which my will had in my humanity."
So now you're going from the humanity to the divinity.
And he has already revealed to her in the hours of the Passion and in all the messages
up to this point in the verse 12 volumes what that divine mission was. And so Louisa alone was
given the revelation about the interior passion of Christ for example.
See how much higher and more sublime this is. My humanity had a beginning but my will is eternal.
My humanity is circumscribed and limited because it's in time and space. My will has no limits
and no boundaries. It is immense. A more noble and distinguished office I could not give you.
On hearing this Louisa said, "My sweet Jesus I can find no reason why you would want to give
me such an office nor have I done anything to deserve such a favor. We cannot deserve God's
favors. It's not actually possible." Grace is the undeserved mercy of God and mercy is undeserved
love. So there's no way we can merit anything. It's given totally from his love.
Jesus answered her, "The whole reason or the motive for choosing you is one, my love,
two, your littleness, and three, your living in my arms like a baby who cares about nothing but
her Jesus alone. And number four, the fact that you've never refused me any sacrifice which I've
asked of you." Now that's very important. Why did Jesus choose her? She says, "I can't think of any
reason why you would." He said, "This is the reason. The reason is divine love, not just for
Louisa but for the whole of humanity." Secondly, your littleness. Now you probably don't remember
a story I told you in the earliest volumes about St. Therese. St. Therese knew in her lifetime that
she was the littlest one on earth and that's why the Lord poured so much grace into her. But before
she died she said to the Lord, "I know that if you found somebody smaller than me that you would pour
oceans of grace into her." And Jesus told Louisa that she was the one that was littler than Therese.
Now Therese is a doctor at the church.
So your littleness. Why was blessed mother chosen because of God's infinite love,
because of her littleness? She said, "I glorify you because of what you've done to your servant."
Her littleness. These things, I'm underlining them because we are coming in after blessed mother
and after Louisa to try and live in this divine will. And so it's God's infinite love for humanity,
not just for us. But this littleness, this nothingness is absolutely, absolutely essential.
And thirdly, her surrender into the arms of God, her abandonment to the divine will.
And that's exactly what blessed mother had as well, abandonment to the divine will.
And this is exactly what we've been talking about in recent times in the messages we have
been dealing with in volume 12, that what God is asking of us is abandonment to his divine will,
that we will just simply throw ourselves into the arms of the Lord and be like a weaned child
on its mother's lap, Sam 131. So the whole motive for choosing Louisa is divine love,
her littleness and her surrender into the arms of God. And the fourth one is that she never
refused him any sacrifice. Now this time I want to bring you to Padre Pio. When Padre Pio was asked
why was it that God worked so many miracles through him, releasing other people from all kinds of
trouble, he said, I never refused him anything, and he never refused me anything. So here is the
fourth thing that we've got to really emphasize, and that is that we don't refuse anything he asks.
In other words, we must be the generous soul. St. Paul tells us in two Corinthians chapter nine
that God loves a cheerful giver. So our generosity to him in accepting any challenge that he gives
to us and in surrendering completely into his arms, not rationalizing about anything,
just doing it. Just throw yourself into the arms of the Lord. Don't do a novena for nine days asking
that this might happen at the end of the nine days. Stop wasting nine days and do it now.
Just say, Jesus, I jump. I'm throwing myself into your arms now, as in now, now, now, now, this instant.
And then having given these four reasons why he chose Louisa, he said, I don't let myself be
impressed by great things, because in the things that appear to be great, there's always something
human. I'm impressed by little things, small in appearance, though great in themselves.
And then you yourself should have understood, he said, that I was to give you a special mission
in my will. Why should she have jumped to this conclusion? Because he had given her such revelation
that he'd never given to anybody before. It was obvious. Well, it's obvious to us looking in on the
thing. And we're like the footballer in inverted commas, sitting at the television, watching the
real people out on the pitch. And of course, we can tell them what they should or should not have
done, because we have a greater perspective, sitting at our television, but we're not involved.
But she was taking this piece by piece by piece, and she was not rationalizing about it,
and she was not coming to conclusions. And he said, you should have known I was preparing you for
something. He said, that continuous speaking to you about my will, that making you understand its
admirably effects, which I've done to know other person until now. I behaved with you like a teacher
who wants his disciple to become perfect, either in medicine or history or whatever.
It seems that he can't speak about anything else. He keeps harping on that one point.
And this is the way I was with you. I assume the attitude of the teacher of divine will,
as if I ignored everything else. And after I instructed you well, I manifested to you your mission
and how the fulfillment of the fiat volunteers to on earth would begin with you.
Courage, my daughter. I see that you're losing heart, he said. Don't fear. You will have all of
my will as your help and support. So the Lord isn't impressed by big things that the human
eagle might be involved in. But he is impressed by little things. And I want to give you an example
of those little things I've given it to you before. And that is that Saint Teresa of Lissue
said that picking up a pin off the floor, how little can it get, picking up a pin off the floor
with the motivation of pure love for God is better than all the projects on the planet.
What makes it better? The pure love for God.
So there's a very important piece of discernment for us to really look into and find out where we're
at in this thing. So while saying this, Jesus caressed Louise's head, face and heart with his
hands, she desperately needed help. So let's come to March the 23rd, 1921. The divine will
renders the soul little and Louise is the littlest of all. So we're back to my story about Thraise.
So I want to give you John 3.30, where John the Baptist was the prophet doing great work in Israel
until he met Jesus. And when he met Jesus, he said, "He must increase and I must decrease."
And then John literally faded off the pages of history and Jesus took over.
And that's the way it is with us when we meet him. We, our big ego, the big important way,
that's got to disappear. The human will has got to lay down itself before the great divine will.
The human love before the divine love.
Louise said, "I was in my usual state. I found myself outside of myself together with Jesus,
and I said to him, 'My love, I want you to hear what I do when I enter into your volition,
to see whether you like it or not.' So I said what I usually say, and she doesn't tell us what it was,
but Jesus was happy with it. So let's come to the second paragraph. Jesus said, "My daughter,
my will has the special power of rendering souls little, making them become so little as
to feel the extreme need of my will to administer life to them." Now, one of the signs that Satan
self or the world are governing your actions is that you appreciate your own importance.
You assert yourself and you assert your rights, etc, etc, which is going on in the world today.
Everybody is saying it's my right to have this that or the other. Everything is my right nowadays.
When somebody has truly met the Lord, you go in the opposite direction
and you begin to realize your littleness and your nothingness and the sign that you
really made progress with God is that that littleness becomes smaller and smaller and smaller.
You become more and more conscious of not only the fragility of human nature,
its weaknesses, your past sins, the sins of the world around you, you become totally conscious
of our complete wretchedness before God. And this is what enables us to really throw ourselves
into the arms of God and let him take over. I want to give you Isaiah 57, 15.
"My will," he said, "has the special power of rendering souls little, making them so little
as to feel the extreme need for my will to administer life to them."
Their littleness is such that they are unable to make one act or take one step if my will
does not administer that act or that step to them. Now this is the total surrender so that
everything inside of us, our desires, our motivations, everything becomes divine will.
We don't do anything of ourselves. So they live completely, that's 100%,
at the expense of my will because their littleness carries no baggage.
Now in the divine will, the baggage allowance is zero, absolute zero. They carry no baggage,
either of things of their own or of the love of self. Rather, they take everything from my will
and they take it not to keep it for themselves, but to give it back to me. And since they need
everything, they live dissolved in my will. Now the goal for us is that our will lives dissolved
in the divine will. That is heaven on earth. It's also Sam 131.
Listen, he said, "I went around the earth over and over again. I looked at all creatures one by one
in order to find the littleest of all. Among many little people, I found you the littleest of all.
In other words, the Lord looks for the most humble person on the earth and the one who will be most
likely to surrender themselves to him." If you look at the people chosen for apparitions of Jesus
and Mary, you will find they choose little people all the time. There's a wonderful story about Saint
Gertrude back. I think it's 10th or 11th century. I'm not completely sure. It might even be 12th
century, which tells you how accurate I am. But she and her sister Mechtild had been orphaned as
children and the relatives gave the two little girls to the local convent and the sisters reared
the two little girls and they eventually became nuns. And so if you fast forward, then you come to
the point where Gertrude became the most famous abyss on the planet. And she was known for her wisdom
and all the rest of it. And Cardinals and bishops and priests and abbots and everybody else came
looking for her advice and her guidance. And one day, Mechtild spoke to the Lord. Now Mechtild
became a saint as well. But one day Mechtild spoke to the Lord and she said, "I have a problem with
this thing that Gertrude is considered the most famous abyss on the planet." Okay, she's obviously
giving a wise advice to all of these people who are coming to her, but they don't know her.
They don't know her like we do. When we go into our office, she could snap us. She could snap at us.
She could lose her patience with us because they were going in with all kinds of trivialities, you know.
And Jesus said to her, "Now I'm giving in my own words. These are not actually Jesus's words."
He said to her, "Gertrude comes to Me 100 times a day asking Me to heal her irritability.
"I won't do it," he said, "because she becomes humbler and humbler every single time she's irritable
with anybody else." He said, "Go away and do likewise. Go and take your irritability to the
Lord. Go and take your impatience to the Lord. Go and take whatever is troubling you to the Lord.
And you too become a saint. Mechtild did." And so you can see that the Lord is looking for the
littlest people of all. And I love that story about Gertrude because the Lord left her with this
fault which even made her sister, who is a very holy woman, criticiser. So on the outside,
we can be rough diamonds. It's terribly important to know that you're a real diamond inside.
Among many, Jesus said, "I found you the littlest of all. I liked your littleness, and so I chose you,
and I entrusted you to my angels so that they might keep you, not to make you grow, but to preserve
your littleness." So there's the angels with their task of looking after those on their way to
salvation. Now that's Hebrews chapter 1 verses 13 to 14. The angels take care of us.
And now I want to begin the great work of the fulfillment of my will, which is the third fiat.
Nor will you feel greater as a result of this. In other words, you won't feel greater as a result
of this. On the contrary, it'll make you even smaller. And you will continue to be the little
daughter of the divine will. And that's beautiful. No matter what God does for us,
he will not allow this puffed up pride thing to enter in and destroy everything.
So April the 2nd, 1921, the soul who operates in the divine will gives for all and receives
for all. In other words, there's no self, no selfishness. There's no me, me, me. That belongs
to a different planet. Louisa said, "I feel my poor mind as though stunned, and I lack the words
to put on paper what I feel. If my Jesus wants me to write, he will dain to say in words what he
infuses in me by means of light." Now notice we've had this now for 12 volumes that Jesus sends her
a light into her intellect, and that's infused knowledge. And immediately she has understanding
without having learned anything. And I mean she hasn't learned anything from books or teachers,
but she has this extraordinary understanding in her being.
I remember that oncoming he said to me, "My daughter, in one who prays, in one who loves,
in one who repairs, in one who kisses me, in one who adores me in my will, I feel as if all were
praying, loving, kissing, and adoring me, etcetera." In fact, since my will envelopes everything and
everyone in my volition, the soul gives me the kiss, the love, and the adoration of all.
And in looking at everyone in her, I give her as many kisses and love that I should give to all.
In my will, the soul is not content. If she does not see me loved fully by all. Now here's
another key for us, for understanding, operating in the divine will, that the love we have for the
Lord is such that we are not content if he's not loved, adored, praised, blessed, worshiped,
served by all souls, past, present, and future. And that's why we keep interceding for that,
because that's what we want. We want him to have complete adoration, complete love, complete service,
etcetera. In my will, the soul is not content. If she doesn't see me fully loved by all.
And if she doesn't see me kissed and adored and prayed by all. In my will, things cannot be
halved on. They must be complete. And I cannot give small things to the soul who acts in my volition.
I give immense things which are sufficient for everyone. I behave with the soul who acts in my
volition like a person who wanted to have a work done by 10 people. Now, only one of these 10 people
offers himself to do the work, all the others refuse. Is it not fair that the Lord give to that one
everything that he should have given to the 10? Otherwise, where would be the difference between
one who acts in my will and one who acts in his own will? So operating at this divine level,
everything is multiplied in a most incredible way. And it's very, very different to praying in the
ordinary way. April the 23rd, 1921. The love of God will triumph over the evils of humanity.
And God will look at the acts of creatures through the acts of the soul done in the divine will.
This is precisely where we get an explanation of why we pray for all in the divine will.
Louisa said I'm going through most bitter days. My always lovable Jesus has almost eclipsed himself.
"What pain?" she said. "What torment?" I just feel my mind beyond the spheres in his will,
Isaiah 57, 15, Philippians 3, 20. Now, I want you to notice what I've just read.
I feel my mind beyond the spheres. In other words, she's no longer on the earth.
She's in heaven. Beyond the spheres is beyond the universe around us.
And I'm in his will. She has gone into that singularity, that one point.
Wanting to take this holy volition and to bring it below the spheres, that is, you now come back
through the whole universe and find planet earth and into the midst of men. And if you
realize that planet earth is only a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe, then you realize
the distance she has to travel. And I want to give it to each one of them as their own life.
So here's somebody operating in the divine will. You yourself can enter into that
august presence, but you want to bring it back with you to the earth to give it to everybody else,
so that everybody else from Adam to Zachary will also have this gift, so that the whole of humanity
can get up and make the journey back to God. She said, "My mind struggles between the divine will
and the human will of all." So there she is in the divine will who wants to come to absolutely
everybody and the human will, which in many, many, many people are still stubbornly opposed
to the divine will. And there she is struggling between one and the other, trying to make them one.
So she's already doing her office that the Lord asked her to do.
Now, while I was at the summit of my bitterness, she said, "My sweet Jesus just barely moved in
my interior and putting out his hands. He took my hands in his and told me in my interior."
So I want you to notice now that Jesus is speaking to her in her interior. This is new. Up to now,
she has been demanding that she would still see him in her exterior, but she's moved,
and the office that she has is completely different. Everything is now entirely spiritual.
So she has to receive him and respond to him in her interior. She has resisted this for a long time.
"My daughter," he said, " courage, I will come, I will come. You must occupy yourself with nothing else but my volition."
That's her job now. Let us leave the earth aside. Now, we're going to hear this a number of times
in these last messages of Volume 12. This is completely new. Let us leave the earth aside,
he said, "They'll get tired of evil." We know that in 1921 that World War II was brewing. In 1921,
the atheistic materialism that was going on in the USSR was at its height. The evil that was
on the earth was unbelievable, and Jesus said, "Let's put it aside. They'll get tired of it."
They will keep sowing terror and frighten sloughers everywhere, but the end will come.
"My will will triumph, and it will triumph over all their evils. Therefore, lay your will within mine."
Notice this, "lay your will within mine." The little one, in the great one, the "I am not in the I am."
And with your acts, you will come to extend a second heaven over the heads of all.
And I will look at the acts of the others through your divine acts, divine because they all start
from my will. And you will force the eternal will to descend below the spheres so as to triumph
over all their human evil. And therefore, if you want my will to descend, and if you want my love
to triumph, you must ascend beyond the spheres. You must dwell up there, and you must extend your
acts in my will. Afterwards, we will descend together. We will assail the creatures with my
evolution and with my love. We will confound them in a way that they will not be able to resist us.
Therefore, for now, let us allow them do what they want. Live in my will and have patience."
Now, this requires actually quite a lot of explanation.
Up to now, we have been used to Jesus coming to Louisa, and he looks all afflicted, or he's in
pain, or he's crucified, or whatever. And that stimulates her in order to make huge reparation
for the sins of humanity, and that in turn mitigates some of the chastisements.
That's over. Jesus says, we're taking a completely different approach now.
We're going to let them get on with their evil.
It's really important to put this alongside the actual history that happened, because evil
seemed to have grown, and grown, and grown, and spread, and spread, and spread. And the whole world
was full of it. You see, in 1917, our blessed mother had said in Fatima that if they don't repent,
and if they don't consecrate Russia to the immaculate heart of Mary and the sacred heart of Jesus,
if they don't do that, Russia will spread her errors all over the world. They have not obeyed,
and so this evil is spreading. So Jesus says, okay, we're not going to engage.
Let them do what they want. That in itself is an unbelievable chastisement,
and I want to give you again Ezekiel, chapters 10 and 11, that if the Lord abandons you,
that is chastimant with all capital letters. I also want to give you Romans, chapter 1,
where St. Paul speaks about the city of Rome having become a cesspool of evil,
and he said, the Lord abandoned them three times, three times, three times. But what does the Lord
do when he abandons them? And so we come now to Jeremiah 29 and 11. What he did to Louisa is he
said, come on, we will create a future full of hope for them. And so he brings her up to a much
higher level of communion with him in the divine will, and he says, you've got to come up into this
high place. So Louisa is the Eagle of God. And for that, I want to give you Proverbs 23,
5b, the second half of the verse. And Proverbs 30, verses 18 to 19.
Deuteronomy 32, verses 11 to 13. Jeremiah 48, verse 40. And Isaiah 40, verse 31.
You're going to have to be doing a lot of scripture study to really get this one. In other words,
the scriptures have prepared us for this. And also the very last stanza of Psalm 22, which is
a huge prophecy about the future. And Psalm 22 spoke about the terror of the crucified one,
and then at the very last stanza, what was the future going to hold? And he said in the end,
the human race will surrender to God. And that's absolutely incredible. And so for the human race
to finally surrender to God, then what God does is that he takes Louisa right up into this
completely new level. I want to read a little bit of this for you.
So this is Psalm 22 from verse 29. And there are other verses as well.
"All the rich of the earth will feast and worship. All who go down to the dust will kneel before him.
Those who cannot keep themselves alive, posterity will serve him. Future generations will be told
about the Lord. They will proclaim his righteousness to a people yet unborn. And this he has done,
consomatim est. That's the consomatim est of the Old Testament. All this God has done. He's done it
for himself. Now here you have what the Lord does when he abandons the earth to its own evil.
And he goes away to prepare a future full of hope for us. And that future full of hope is
that after he has to do a very severe chastisement to purify the earth, that a new era of the new
and divine holiness will open up for humanity. So I want to give you also Isaiah 64 verses 1 to 2
and the prophet Joel chapter 3. And it should be verses 1 to 10 or something like that.
So Louisa has to go higher up, literally live in heaven to do this divine work with the divine
will and then bring it down to the earth. So April the 26th 1921. The war which the divine will
will rage on creatures. Now once this work is done between Louisa and Jesus and all the foundations
of the era of the new and divine holiness are laid down, what's going to happen then?
Louisa said, "I continue in my painful state. My sweet Jesus came for just a little and drawing
me strongly to himself, he told me. My daughter, I repeat it to you, do not look at the earth."
Now we're taking our eyes off planet earth. We're not going to look at what's going on there.
Let them do what they want. They want to make war, so be it. When they get tired,
I too will make my war. But his war is different.
Their tiredness and evil, their disenchantments, their disillusiones, the losses that they suffer
will dispose them to receive my war. And my war will be a war of love. Now if you go to
2 Corinthians 10 from verse 4, Saint Paul tells us that the weapons of our warfare are not carnal,
but they're mighty for bringing down the strongholds of evil.
And I want to give you Psalm 145 verse 17 that God only ever acts out of love. So my war will
be a war of love. My will will descend from heaven into their midst. All of your acts and those of
others done in my volition. That's us. Isn't that fantastic? Our little acts count as well.
All of your acts and those of others done in my volition will wage war on humanity.
But not a war of blood. They will wage war with weapons of love, giving them gifts,
graces and peace. They will give such surprising gifts as to astonish ungrateful humanity.
This will of mine is the militia of heaven. We are God's army.
Bringing the weapons of love and joy and peace and patience and kindness and goodness to the
whole of humanity, I think that's beyond brilliant. So 2 Corinthians 10 verses 3 to 6 and 2 Kings
chapter 6 verses 14 to 17. Now in the book of Kings, you'll find that in the Old Testament,
God's army were always the angels, always. And when Elisha was caught in a tight spot and he saw
the angels on the mountains all around him, God's army had arrived. But we're the terrestrial angels
that God is going to use to bring this new era about. This will of mine is the militia of heaven
and it will confound man with divine weapons. It will overwhelm him and it will give him the light
in order to see because they're living in total blindness now.
And what are they to see? Not the evil that they've experienced but the gifts and the riches with
which I want to enrich them. There's the absolute total immense, magnificent, beyond magnificent
love of God that instead of just condemning man for all that he has done and continues to do,
that he entices him with the most incredible gifts.
This will of mine, militia of heaven will confound man with divine weapons. It will overwhelm him
and will give him the light in order to see not evil, but the gifts and the riches with which
I want to enrich him. The acts on in my will, carrying the creative power within themselves,
that's why they're so powerful, will be the new salvation of man.
And descending from heaven, they will bring all goods upon the earth. Now it's the acts on in my will,
will bring all goods to the earth and they will bring the new era of peace and joy and love to the
earth. And they will also bring the triumph over human iniquity and therefore the triumph of the
two hearts of Jesus and Mary. Therefore multiply your acts in my will to form the weapons, the
gifts and the graces so as to be able to descend into the midst of creatures and wage the war of
love on them. Amen. Then in a more afflicted tone Jesus said, "My daughter, it will happen to me
as to a poor father whose wicked children not only offend him, but they want to kill him also."
This is that the outlawing of Christ and Christianity began with the French Revolution,
went into communism, went all through the USSR and is now gone to the whole earth.
"I'm like a father," he said, "whose wicked children not only offend him,
but want to kill him." And if they don't do it, it's because they're not actually able to do it.
Now since these children want to kill their father, it's no wonder that they want to kill one
another. Interesting. That one is against the other and that they impoverish themselves
and they reach the point of being in the act of dying. What's worse is that they even remember,
they don't even remember, they have a father. In other words, people like in this country in
Ireland, which has been saturated with Christianity for a thousand, five hundred years. It's forgetting
it has a savior. Mind-boggling. Now what does the father do? Exiled by his own children,
while these fight and wound one another and they're about to die of starvation, that's spiritual
starvation. The father works hard in order to acquire new riches, gifts, and remedies for his
children. So that's exactly the point at which Jesus has brought Louisa. While humanity is killing
one another in the millions, that he and Louisa go off to acquire new riches in the acts in the
divine will to bring them back to wage the war of love on humanity. And when he sees humanity
almost lost, he goes into their midst to make them richer. Now this is a very important point
and it has come to us in a number of prophecies as well and that is that God, when God steps back
and allows humanity to do what it wants, he waits until it's almost at the point of despair
and then he moves in and he saves the whole thing. It seems that that move of waiting,
I call it the cliffhanger move, at what point is the rope going to break?
It seems that he knows that we have to get to that point before we will look at him.
Isn't that scary? And when he sees them almost lost, he goes into their midst and he makes them
richer. He offers remedies for their wounds and brings peace and happiness to all. That means that
the saints of the future will be working miracles, miracles of healing and resurrection and exorcism
and everything. And then humanity conquered by so much love. These children will bind themselves
to their father with a lasting peace and will love him. So having experienced this explosion of love
in the face of their ingratitude, they will actually commit themselves to the Lord.
"The same will happen to me," he said. "Therefore, I want you in my will as a faithful daughter
of my volition, and I want you at work together with me to acquire new riches to be given to the
creatures. Be faithful to me and occupy yourself with nothing else." So we have to wait for God's
kyros time, the right moment for his intervention. But in the meantime, we join Louisa and blessed
mother in making as many acts in the divine will as is possible so that we are part of the solution
to planet earth. Now that's the end of Volume 12.